welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down the crown season
6 the first part of the season has just
released on Netflix and the four
episodes have a lot that we need to talk
about there's some major differences
that I want to cover in the video but I
also want to discuss some of the
similarities that the show has to real
life like The Witcher and latest
stranger things season Netflix have
decided to split things up and thus the
second part of season 2 will be
releasing later in the air there's a lot
of things we know about the real life
history 2o and we can kind of determine
where we're going to be going throughout
this video we're going to be discussing
it all and if you enjoy it then please
hit the thumbs up don't forget to
subscribe for our second part of the
coverage as we'll also be tackling the
last half too without the way huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
the crown season
6 now the main focus of season six set
cers around the lead up to Diana's death
and the aftermath of it throughout the
episodes we see her getting closer to
Dodie after season five had her going on
the sandree holiday as we saw last
season Dodie was engaged and in real
life this was to model Kelly Fischer
after Dy and Diana were first
photographed in July 1996 she then held
a press conference to announce a lawsuit
against him this was obviously dropped
in the aftermath of dy's death but it
did add to the negative press
surrounding him which we see playing out
in the show the series even has is at
one point getting focused on two
photographers with one being a member of
the Paparazzi while the other sort of
documents things purely for the Royals
really shows the differences and nuances
to the industry with the former being
painted out more like a vulture the
positive press for die leads to Charles
having his own photo shoots with his
sons which is something that also
happened in real life there is also the
conflict between the queen and Camila
which has been well documented by Royal
historians according to the independent
the queen referred to her as a wicked
woman to Charles's face once and it was
made clear that she wouldn't be Queen
back in 2005 it was stated that she
would become the princess consort
instead of the queen consort however
over the years she apparently grew
closer to the queen during the 2020s it
was told that she would eventually be
Queen and this was apparently done while
the queen was still alive and thus it
hasn't really caused any issues now one
of the big points of contention in the
episode is what happens on the night
that Dody and Diana die the pair go to
Dodd's room and it's at this point that
he ends up proposing after being
rejected the pair talk about how they're
going to make major changes is without
he promising to be straight up with his
father about how he feels according to
the show his dad had put a lot of
pressure on him to propose and become a
man that he just didn't want to be
before he makes an ultimatum about
cutting him off he then hangs up the
call and goes off on a rant about how he
really feels now whether any of these
events happened is of course another
thing entirely as is the buildup to them
that happens throughout the season one
of the main things we see happening
though is Muhammad hiring a photographer
and this is to take photos of his sudden
and Di on a yacht this is said to be the
best photographer in the Mediterranean
with it being a big breach of privacy
that causes some issues apparently this
never happened though Muhammad was happy
when the photo got released he said to
have been grinning gleefully at it
showing it around to all of his friends
however it has to be said we don't know
if he hired the photographer now on top
of this other statements alleg that
Diana might have tipped off the
paparazzi to where they were with the di
of Chronicles alleging that she tipped
them off according to the independent
perie had been told by her that they'd
be on that yacht with her wanting the
photo to be taken either way though it's
clear they stepped over the line and
went way too far in harassing the pair
which eventually led to their death as
for the proposal that didn't actually
happen however doy did buy an engagement
ring like what we see in the show The
Ring had been delivered at odies and it
was thought that he would have popped
the question eventually engraved on it
with the words tell me yes in French
with him making a joke about tell me no
during the scene originally though it
was this more we which happens to be the
name of the third entry hounded through
the night we don't really see the crash
and instead view it from the perspective
of a dog walker this symbolically shows
how the public saw it too with us not
really being near it but it being
impactful to us all in episode 4 Charles
correctly predicts how big it's going to
be with the event being something
reported on a worldwide scale I and so
many people I talked to about this
moment they all remember where they were
when she died with it being something
that greatly impacted a lot of people
now further element of the aftermath of
it are played out in the queen with her
focus on Elizabeth's stealing of the
events it's quite a controversial moment
in Royal history with 70% of Brits
apparently being angered that the queen
refused to acknowledge it however in the
end she was apparently persuaded by Tony
Blair and put out a broadcast with the
family attending her funeral in the end
Blair also plays a big part in episode
one with them going to the queen to ask
if she can have her oil position this
apparently happened as well with Diana
being given the position of overseas
Ambassador her Legacy of course weighs
heavily on the world including her work
with landmines that we see in the show
episode 4 very much Chronicles the
public events after with several of the
characters being visited by visions of
Tai it's in this that we do see the
Queen's reluctance to put herself out
there with Charles let convincing her to
be mother to the nation now one of the
main divides between the family and D
was the fact that the L knew how to work
the pr in a positive way she seemed to
be out there constantly helping others
whereas they were viewed as being more
private and reserved a public funerals
worried to be a huge spectacle and in
the end it was a widely covered event
behind closed doors the queen apparently
struggled with the fact they were
expected to grieve and show emotion
which is something that they tackle in
the season keep calm and carry on you
know that's something the Royals have
basically made a stereotype and the
stiff upper lip kind of derives from
them Blair however convinced her that
the world had changed now the meteor and
PR would be what kept the family stable
at the time a quarter of people wanted
to abolish the monarchy which some
chocked up to their detachment from the
public in the shaft at ai's funeral the
Queen's visited by Dana's ghost with
Elizabeth talking how much she shook up
things with the family firsty there was
of course a divorce and then the
interview with Mar Basher that talked
about how controlling the life of a
royal was lastly in death she also
exposed the public issues we've
discussed and it's very clear she was a
very divisive figure in the family now
Diana very much hammers home the point
that she's basically showed what it
means to be British but in the end she
has to demonstrate that she's ready to
be too in the end she gives her public
speech with the queen paying respect to
Diana which is shot in the same way that
the broadcast appeared in real life now
he CLS out with William Harry and
Charles walking behind the carriage with
Diana's coffin with people being able to
see the loss in their faces for the
first time this in itself was highly
publicized too with it being
heartbreaking having to watch two sons
that had just lost their mother in the
end we have the Queen by her bed praying
and she has a glance almost to see if
Diana's ghost there in the end nothing
appears but it shows this plays on her
mind however her not showing up shows
that she did the right thing now that
takes us into where the second part is
going to go and we actually know a fair
bit about it releasing on December 14th
it's going to have a time Jump that will
pick up with a slightly older William
when he meets Cape Middleton photos of
this have been released online and it'll
primarily center around his time at St
Andrew's College it'll also lean more to
Charles and Camila with a pair of course
going on to n Ru nation and the more
controversial aspects like Andrew and so
on that won't be covered and we also
won't be getting a Netflix suits
crossover it's going to be the final
season of the crown with us also not
getting a season 7 and we will leave
things off where there's still a lot of
story to unpack when you look at the
history in the end it's kind of
difficult to judge the season without
knowing where it's going to go from here
but again I thought the series has had a
pretty solid entry when the show first
started the crowns coverage of Diana was
always something that people wondered
about how they were going to tackle it I
know it's getting slam for taking such a
focus on it and there's a lot of
controversy about the death especially
the ghosts I think with this it was
always going to be difficult to handle
it respectfully but the actual Parts I
think were quite well put together where
it tends to fall down as always is in
the creative license stuff like the
proposal and the drama that pay people
in a certain way I think had this been
released as a full season them people
may not have been as hard but the
guardian gave it one star I think steady
cut did too and the best review I could
find was from USA Today who gave it two
and a half now is it that bad no I don't
think so and I think had this been
purely a drama that it would have been
fine however with they focusing on real
life people and an event that people
strongly remember it has angered some
especially with how they've handled
certain aspects personally I don't think
it was that bad but I also think it's
probably the weakest season of the crown
so far at least uh it is obviously going
to be interesting to see how it wraps up
next month and at that point I'll give
it a full score at the moment though
it's probably sort of a three out of
five six out of 10 sort of thing but I
feel like the season being cut in half
has damaged it quite a bit I don't know
if the finale is going to be hurt by
that too but obviously let me know your
thoughts on the show below please like
the video if you've enjoyed it if you've
learned something and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button you'll get early access to
videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us out now if you
want something else to watch we've got a
break down on screen right now including
Monarch which is just dropped today Mt
is going over all the Godzilla and Kong
Easter eggs in it so definitely head
over there right after this but out the
way thank you for sing through the video
I've been your host Paul I'll see you
next
[Music]
time
oh